نعم هي اكبر مفاجاتي كاس العالم وليس وصفا
لتعظيم الانتصار وانما احصائيات ودلائل من
قبل شركه البيانات نيلسوند حدثت المفاجاه
بهذا الملعب ملعب لوسيل في الدوحه الذي
شهد اللقاء التاريخي هنا شاهد نحو ثمانين
الف متفرجا ام مباراه لن ينسوها سواء
الفرحا بالسعوديه او حزن على الارجنتين
نسبه الفوز المتوقع هي الاقل عبر كل كؤوس
العالم ثمانيه فاصله 7% السعوديه المصنفه
51 عالميا صنعت المستحيل امام المصنف
الثالث والمرشح لقب المونديال الارجنتين
تقدمت الارجنتين بهدف للنجم الابرز طبعا
ليونيل ميسي في الدقيقه العاشره عن طريق
ركله جزاء وهنا ضمن الجميع ان النتيجه
ستكون كبيره على الاخضر لكن النتيجه
استمرت هكذا حتى جاء الشوط الثاني لم
ينتظر السعوديون كثيرا التعادل في الدقيقه
الثامنه والاربعين باقدام صالح الشهري اول
اهداف السعوديه على الاطلاق في كاس العالم
ضد فريق سبق له حمل لقب
خمسه ودقائق اخرى كانت كفيله من اجل الهدف
الثاني سالم الدوسري وبمهاره كبيره يسكن
الكرات في شباك الارجنتين لتتحقق المفاجاه
لكن كيف حدثت
المدير الفرنسي للمنتخب السعودي هو السبب
الابرز كما نشاهد نسبه امتلاك الكره كانت
للارجنتين كانت 69% مقابل 31 للسعوديه
امرنا منطقي وطبيعي بالنظر لامكانات
الفريقين لكن حيله خطيره لاعبه عليها
لنهار وطبقت بشكل رائع من قبل لاعبيه
مصياده التسلل التي كانت سببا من اسباب
الفوز وقعت الارجنتين في التسلل 10 مرات
منها ثلاث مرات احرزت فيها اهدافا والغيا
مقابله مره واحده على السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا بالطبع بجانبي بسالتي لاعبي المنتخب
السعودي التي منحت العرب انتصارا هو
الابرز مشاهدينا في كؤوس العالم